shark still dealing with a fair bit of injury
issues including tonight no toas hurle suffered
a lower body injury will borgan with a slap
shot off a shark skate could not be extended
to a fourth as Buffalo played very well here
on Saturday a chance for the Kraken and will
or pince done rather all the way down at the
creas nice attempt there from duclair and
this is done the defenseman you mentioned light
sched in the NHL tonight this is the only other
game remaining so wherever you're watching Sharks
hockey tonight here at the Shark Tank we welcome
you on NBC Sports California Caleb Addison back
in the lineup for the Sharks on defense tonight
here's a turnover to Brandon tanon and Blackwood
makes a big save here in the first period back
to Alexia he'll go BL High and missed the target
as that one will deflect up into the nettic huk
looking to go from this left side wing all the way
across and he just times it perfectly steps into
that passing Lane looking for the five hole and
Blackwood comes up large here to save the turnover
there for the Sharks gun now York Strand they'll
hold on the BS to get it back out to McAn he'll
load up knocked down with he bl by Blackwood now
McAn turns away from pressure dropping his stick
was zelin but he's got it back is GRA as d goes to
the net again another save by black classic sells
out trying to clear it but it was kept in by Dunn
non-stop pressure here by the Krakens dun to the
net again black would have saved and Mackenzie
Blackwood a busy penalty kill shift here only 20
seconds to go there hasn't been a change by either
team done back up top he'll load up given to manen
his shot saved by Blackwood rebound WI ber tried
to tap it over to Bor strand here's mccad baronov
skates to Center over to duclair finds the SE
backand pass for eckan just a little ahead of
it here's toas Tatar a weird year for him started
with Colorado there a free agent here's William
Eckman brings it into the cracking Zone into
the corner for duclair big Alexia a there but
deair moves it that get shot off the glove of dor
cinen back across for Dunn dun to the net looking
for the tip in front York Strand who will be the
Krakens Allstar participant there and he's got it
again and another save for Blackwood Andre bski
back for borgan now Alex put it on net and that's
swallowed up again in the grease by McKenzie
Blackwood top heavy offense they got from the
forward group last year guys like bers just has
not been there at the same level this season plus
they lost a lot of guys in the off SE 44 games
in the season here 45 games it's hard and you
see some of the things that you want the coach
to implement like finishing checks marov takes
it from fellow Russian Shakir L Mullan was up
ended on his way to that lo spck as Cain puts
one last shot on net and that'll do it for period
number one he can move the puck back there very
good Puck analysis chance for bers and blackw stop
that he comes back out in front K with a couple of
waack at it York Strand there givs it to borgan
at the point now with Yanni C Alexia right to
the net and the unscreen Mackenzie Blackwood able
to make that stop a third round dra pick with the
Columbus had one big goal scoring here he scored
28 for the jacket and then they traded him to
the Kraken the backhander by Gord is handled by
Blackwood played at Providence four years had a
nice career there but you don't think that's going
to be your own goal shot by sadena handled by dord
back to Philip sadena it goes now a hooku and Miss
on that one and it creates a possible three out
two here for Seattle Schwarz cier and that one
blocked by a hul you it dropped him he's back
up on his skate couple of back to- back shifts
there by the Sharks their best two shifts of the
game getting some offensive zone time here here's
a turnover Gard y strand hit the post second post
tonight for Seattle bgan across B strand denied
by Blackwood good hustle shift tolven comes up
with the turnover at gourd and there's that little
deflection off black fling this is Zin it's going
to be another two-minute with the same groups out
there's a shot save by D cour erson back for the
Sharks and to give away and Everly
with the dagle and a nice save by
Blackwood kept Alive by Seattle at the line
Everly to the late man lson and Larson e by
McKenzie Blackwood there's the no look pass into
Larson coming in from the point and right there
in the glove is and Bailey responds by getting
the puck back on a good battle on K that's what
you want to see done then off the skate of
glenberg burkovski and Blackwood with a stick
save Eckland leaves his way through Eckland across
the Seattle line still with it emberson bling
scor Mark Edward bling and the
sharks are on the board it's one
nothing he brings it all the way from the
defensive Zone comes through here sharks
thought they should have been a penalty right
there on the hook still has it through that
traffic D to D shot right coming went through
vasic you can see Schultz Crossing in front of
his own goal tender as vasic now continues to ride
the hot stick as fourth of the Season finds a hole
and that's turned over at the line to hoopman
hoopman drops for zman zman the cross and the
court diving out kept that out of the net generate
any scoring in this one thanes it a large part to
McKenzie black with 27 saves so far tonight for
Blackwood here's McAn is delay shoots and that
one looked like it went off the crossbar and out
of play in a position to release this acid of him
this shot just pivots just a little bit slows
down and then he releases it wber in for the
Kraken lber battling emberson who stays with him
now out to Gordon saved by Blackwood available at
the side Blackwood try to reach out and grab that
good done jork Strand and now McAn McAn drops for
done done yor Str looking for a lane gets it wide
and Ruda will send it the length of the ice and
score and for the third time this month glassic
and Ruda have scored in the same game look at the
fiveman unit right in front kind of a playing
card by tight puck gets deflected then misses
the net rout to just turning fire what a shot
shot by Ruda gets his third of the Season as it
goes in and splits the uprights and what a shot
from a turn and fire and he takes a lift of the
hand and tipped his cap to the his teammates
for a great job there take care of business
for the Sharks arm this Tuesday night at the
Shark Tank dub gives it away C with one last
scoring chance for the Sharks perhaps and it's
up and out of play well what a response here
in the third period by the Sharks good energy
Conan getting it going with the scrap and the
sharks get the first goal and get the next one
from Ruda a couple of back-to-back goals from
defenseman McDonald off the draw to cord the
save and that is going to do it the San Jose
Sharks come alive in the third period they get
a 32 save performance for McKenzie Blackwood